working on a film or tv set can be a lot
between long hours and harsh conditions
it can be an exhausting and dangerous
place to be
and even the most carefully staged stunt
can end in disaster
this seems especially true of netflix's
spanish crime series money heist so
let's take a look at some of the times
that the cast and crew were put in real
danger
since you've decided to hang out let's
get started shooting a show like money
heist is more than blazing hot lights
freezing cold sound stages and plentiful
tripping hazards it's also stunts and
lots of them plenty of movies and tv
shows have a scene where a person
tumbles on a rope or chain and stops
just short of hitting the ground but
there's usually a lot of digital
trickery involved not so on money heist
remember that scene where the professor
is wrapped in chains and takes a long
tumble and narrowly avoids smacking into
the concrete floor well there's a lot
that goes into executing a stunt like
that and it's still not necessarily safe
to overcome the risks of the stunt
alvero morte had to be secured in such a
way that his chains couldn't tighten or
pinch him while still appearing to
unroll around him as he falls and a
specially cut guide rope had to be
attached to his belt to stop him from
getting too close to the floor the final
effect makes for a sudden stop but
thankfully not one that landed the actor
with a face full of concrete
for our first accident well don't play
with knives kids while shooting money
heist's final season there's a scene
where hovik kuch kirian playing bogota
has a confrontation with the captured
security chief caesar gandhia played by
jose manuel poga for the scene kukuryan
has a knife in one hand and has to press
its blade against poga's skin the scene
went off just fine but there was one
problem the knife which was supposed to
be a prop was actually real and so was
the blood that was coming out of poga's
shoulder this prop mix-up thankfully
only cost the actor a few stitches and
he was immediately able to return to
work but things certainly could have
been a lot worse
since it seems like i'm fully channeling
your mom now here's another rule don't
play or run by the pool
shooting on or in the water is
notoriously dangerous for film and tv
crews
long hours in pools can drain actors and
offer a false sense of security and
shooting on the open water is even worse
miles from land and largely exposed to
the elements water shoots aren't just
perilous they're hard to get help for
when something does go wrong
so of course money heist had to get in
on that action too right
for one of the crew's dramatic escapes
out into international waters the
production moved to a shooting location
off the coast of thailand it was hot out
there with some actors reporting
temperatures of 45 degrees centigrade
that's
113 degrees for our fahrenheit using
viewers
and because the crew had escaped wearing
cold weather gear
well in cold weather gear they had to
stay
combine the heat and those clothes with
the rolling seas that they were shooting
on and the actors weren't just throwing
up and trying not to fall off the boat
they were at risk of overheating things
were so bad in fact that actor miguel
herron suffered a heat stroke saying of
the experience that it was hot as hell
and his co-star esther acebo admitted
that the conditions had the cast and
crew ready to quit then and there saying
we all just wanted to die we're sure
anyone who has ever been seasick would
agree with her
since we're already hanging out by the
pool let's talk a little about that
flooded vault scene where denver actor
jaime lorente has to dive through the
set in scuba gear to recreate the fact
that the bank of spain's gold vault will
allegedly really flood in the event of a
robbery the production had to build an
entire set on location at britain's
famous pinewood l street studios and
sink it into a pool
diving is always tricky and when you're
shooting in a submerged enclosed set
like that you're effectively cave diving
one of the most dangerous things that
humans have ever decided to do for fun
weighed down by heavy equipment and
fully submerged it can be easy for
divers to become disoriented and panic
in small enclosed spaces like the set of
course shooting on a sound stage meant
that there were plenty of safeguards in
place but being trapped down under the
water like that is always dangerous and
scary
wait for action before you go
okay
but enough of this water stuff let's
talk about something even more perilous
fire during the ammunition depot
sequence the crew of money heist stuck
to their guns of doing as many effects
practically as possible and handed actor
enrique arce who played arturo a real
flamethrower described by the actor as a
little heavy very tiring and very hot
flamethrowers are serious business many
of them can produce a flame that reaches
3000 degrees
and spraying meters of raging fire
around like that come on you don't need
us to tell you how dangerous that is
here's another fiery fact that was
probably way too tightly controlled to
be truly dangerous to anyone
but it's way too cool not to include
the set for the bank of spain's gold
museum and banquet hall was so intensely
detailed that it took 50 craftsmen
180 days to construct
that's six months of work for a location
so naturally they also had to blow it up
you only see the actual set for about a
minute and a half of screen time before
it explodes in a glorious
single take fireball and frankly we
wouldn't have had it any other way
on a show like money heist everyone gets
blown up eventually pyrotechnics like
flames sparks and controlled explosions
are staples of action filmmaking and so
are the risks according to series star
ursula corbeiro she was once crouched
low against a column waiting to return
fire during a gunfight when she received
instructions that she was clear to move
unfortunately those instructions came a
little early and a pyrotechnics effect
went off next to her head the actress
was unhurt but she said i start to smell
like burnt chicken it was my hair that
was on fire in fact it wasn't my hair it
was the wig which was even worse because
that burns more
before we go let's cook up one more
s'more by the fire after making off with
the bank of spain's gold the heist crew
renders the gold bars down into small
untraceable nuggets to do this the
showrunners even committed to showing us
real details deciding to actually build
a smelter on set and melt down the bars
on camera the bronze bars that the
smelting crew melted were very real and
so was the temperature on set the
melting point of bronze is a sweltering
1675 degrees that's enough to make even
the trained professionals the show used
uncomfortable
and there you have it la casa de papel
has been a massive hit for netflix both
here and abroad
and it's easy to see why
the unique shooting conditions and
blockbuster stunts make for a show
unlike any other
and we're just scratching the surface
be sure to sound off with some of your
favorite stunts and money heist moments
in the comments